the British chemicals and technology
company Johnson Matthey released its
annual figures earlier today recording a
pre-tax profit of just under half a
billion pounds and revenue of more than
12 billion the company can trace its
origins back precisely 200 years to the
day when Percival Johnson started off as
a gold share these days it makes a whole
range of products glass metals medicines
but one of its mainstays is catalytic
converters used to take emissions out of
engines and those emissions are a topic
we've heard quite a lot about recently
here in the studio with me is Robert
McLeod chief executive of Johnson
Matthey Robert evening to you let's kick
off with those those emissions
dieselgate was a nightmare for VW was it
actually rather good used for you well
this obviously brought the topic of
emissions very much into the public eye
and of course that's where we are a part
of the solution because our products are
there are catalytic converters are there
to help take those harmful pollutants
out of the atmosphere and in fact last
year we took out more than 20 million
tons of pollutants and stopped them from
entering the atmosphere across the world
engines want to be around forever
certainly diesel and petrol engines
won't be around um how are you adapting
to a future that is likely to be
electric well I think diesel and petrol
cars are going to be here for some time
to come but we are investing in
batteries - so we've got a battery
technologies business so we're investing
in the new generation of battery
materials so that clever bit that goes
inside the cell that makes the battery
last longer or go further is safe and
that needs a better material and that's
where we can use our chemistry expertise
to make a better material we're
investing in that today that is a
fiercely competitive field at the moment
I mean there's everyone from Tesla to
Panasonic to Ford all working on battery
technology how how are you going to find
the niche for Johnson Matthey well I
think it's all about the chemistry and I
think people are doing very different
things what Tesla are doing is totally
different for Panasonic are doing panas
on and being a supplier to Tesla but we
would be a supplier to somebody like
Panasonic they're not going to have all
the chemistry expertise that we have and
so we will be a supplier to them and
what we believe is you can make a better
material you can make a better battery
which will
further than the cell companies will
want it and then the car companies will
want it from the cell manufacturer so
that's the niche we want to play what do
you think is the the range the Trucial
range that we need to get over because
still people worry that a electric car
won't go far enough they're concerned
about that how far does it need to go
before we all stop worrying well I think
it's a little bit more than just range I
think it's charging time and I think
it's predictability because it obviously
did varies by temperature and VY by the
whole environment so I think we already
against two to three hundred miles and
it can charge very quickly then I think
that's something people will go for more
it's not the time to cover massage you
about breaks it that mean
pharmaceuticals so many things you you
do are hugely regulated lots of European
regulations involved her what are you
gonna do about braixen well we've said
before the breaks have happened and I
think we'll find a way to navigate
through this I mean you said with 200
years old we've been through two world
wars to name two things that have been
very traumatic for the country so we
will get through this all right I mean
what we want to do is make sure that we
work with government to come up with a
process that works effective your
industry for us what matters as much as
possible as to allow that movement of
trade as easily as possible
because of course that will just
lengthen supply chains if it becomes too
too long and too arduous so we're
working with government on that and I
think the Devils in the detail and all
these things very easy to make big
sweeping statements but it'll all come
down to individual contracts individual
clauses and a few pharmaceutical
companies have suggested they're looking
at relocating to Europe or at least
setting up subsidiary would you look at
doing anything I mean you're
headquartered in Britain at the moment
Britain there's no plans at all to move
our headquarters we are investing we
announced today investing in a new plant
in Poland but that has nothing to do
with brexit that's because we need
capacity and unflexible an efficient
plant so no I think we'll carry on being
a UK company
for the next 200 years thank you very
much indeed good to hit good to hear
that ringing endorsement
Robert Robert MacArthur a chief
executive of a Johnson Matthey